simple way you can cheat the system
here's how to make DIY foam soap a lot
of you tagged me in this because you
probably thought I would have strong
feelings and you are right please don't
do this again it is a preservative
problem these types weren't made to be
diluted the preservative system was
tested to work at the original
concentration diluting means they can't
work as well to stop bacteria and mold
from growing plus he's diluting it a lot
which means that the pH is going to
become a lot more neutral making it a
friendly environment for microbes it
could also make the preservatives
inactive it is really not good value if
you end up with more germs on your hands
after washing them if you really want to
save money on soap just don't press the
pump down the whole way don't waste all
your soap